in his epic story the Lord of the Rings
Junior Tolkien creates the one magical
object which has most fascinated the
modern imagination the One Ring in the
epic binds together many patterns which
we intuitively grasp but we might not
know why such an object is so
intuitively accepted by us why is it a
ring why does it grant invisibility
grant unnatural long life why does it
corrupt and why does it participate in a
dark inverted hierarchy of power
hopefully I'll be able to give some
insight into the pattern and how all
those elements I mentioned are coherent
together
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
tokens ring in the Lord of the Rings is
like an inverted Holy Grail
the object of everyone's desire though
not for the personal challenge it offers
and for the spiritual enlightenment it
procures but rather for the raw power
which it contains and which it gives to
its where an ancient myth and in
storytelling we find other such rings
the ring of guy Jesus in Plato's
Republic whose capacity to render
invisible entices guide ease to give
into his raw desire for power by using
the ring to use herb the king in
Arthurian legend Sir Gawain is given a
invisibility ring and then we also find
sir Percival who receives a ring that
makes him invulnerable there is also the
ring of the Nibelungen vogner's Opera
which is based on ancient Nordic legend
in which an evil ring becomes the focus
of desire and the cause of a downfall
token in his version of the magic ring
intuitively binds together all these
previous elements because if in the
hobbit we discover only a ring of
invisibility in the Lord of the Rings it
takes on an almost cosmic function as
the focus of all power and desire
the Dark Lord Sauron has forged the ring
as it is said three rings for the Elven
kings under the sky 7 for the dwarf
Lords in their halls of stone 9 for
mortal men doomed to die we see in these
three lines the setup of a hierarchy
which follows the hierarchy set up in
middle-earth you know we see three rings
for the near godlike being the elves
under the sky that are qualified as
Kings for for the dwarves who are
described as Lords inhabiting their
halls and most 9 for men who are
characterised only by their mortality
and are last in this hierarchy their
destined to inherit the earth when the
other races leave or dwindle but the one
ring is for the Dark Lord on his dark
throne in the land of Mordor where the
shadows lie as it is said one ring to
one ring - and so the hierarchy of the
ring becomes a hierarchy of dark power
which places the Dark Lord at its head
and the Rings given to the people become
subject and bound in their power to the
owner of the One Ring this binding
appears in the very shape of the ring as
a band a circle which marks and
surrounds the wear with its power the
notion that a ring is a form of binding
to oneself is something we can still
understand today as this is the purpose
of placing a wedding band around our
spouse it binds them to us just like it
bound the owners of the multiple rings -
Sauron who had made and given them the
Rings because we tend to think of magic
as something only for the fantasy realm
we often neglect to understand what
magic needs and so stories with magic
and you know enchanted objects can
appear only as a form of whimsical
entertainment rather such stories can
contain much wisdom about human activity
we can understand stories about magic in
the same manner we can understand
stories about technology about personal
or political power simply about the
development of some means to affect the
world around us we also are used to to
think of technology and magic as being
opposites to each other but rather than
understanding how they have the same
function we might be able to access more
profound truths about them
you see both technology and magic just
like other forms of increasing our power
follow the process that we could call a
process of supplement
the supplement is simply adding to
ourselves
adding to ourselves what we could call
tools in order to make us more capable
of protecting ourselves but also of
affecting the world we live in writing
itself as part of this civilization but
think of anything think of medicine
transportation a house a cell phone a
weapon or else an amulet
a spell a potion all examples of things
we add like layers to our nakedness to
make us more powerful the primordial
technology is clothing for its immediate
imagery of covering to protect one from
the outside world this is of course the
first technology which appears in the
Bible but technology in its most
developed form is often characterized as
mythologically you know in the stories
as forging of metal in the Bible it is
tubal-cain who forges the first weapons
of war he's a descendant of the murderer
Cain who had found in the first city
after being ejected from the presence of
God in Greek and Roman mythology was the
god Hephaestus or Vulcan who forged
weapons he was a deformed God with a
lame foot who had been tossed from Mount
Olympus the mountain of the gods you can
see that in both those stories the
development of technology is a paradox
like any tool it both makes us more
powerful while also covering a weakness
and also making us dependent on its
power think ultimately of the famous
story of Icarus who having forged
artificial wings is now in danger of
falling to his death which he does after
flying too close to the Sun something he
could not have done without the very
power that those Wings gave him part of
the paradox of Technology
is how it is that increase in one's
capacity an answer to a problem and in
that sense it is related to light to
glory
think of how intuitively right is a
light saber or how power and so many
movies is represented as light emanating
from a person but because technology and
the supplement in general is an adding
of layers and because it is linked to
materiality it can also hide off escape
what it is protecting or the very act of
protecting in this way it is also a form
of darkening and so the mine the cave
and the underground fire participates in
this imagery and the movie version of
the Lord of the Rings developed by Peter
Jackson this dark element of technology
is portrayed very well as we these
weapons and these armors are shown being
forged in the caves of is in guard and
how this recalls the god Vulcan forging
metal from his own underground world
medicine is also a form of supplement
like the taking of magic potions or
treatments which participate in the
paradox that I've mentioned this paradox
of technology medicine both makes us
stronger facing our own mortality but
also it makes us weaker for being you
know for becoming dependent on the power
which this medicine offers the ring of
power making one live unnaturally long
can easily be understood analogically by
how today we have created all kinds of
drugs machines respirators and other
strange contraptions which can maintain
one artificially alive we can deny this
of course can be of great use to people
who are in a difficult situation though
we also know that it can go too far and
it can keep someone indefinitely alive
in a state
that is not fully human and so when
looking at the ring of power through
this frame we can see that it unites
many of the elements already mentioned
it is forged it is metal it is a type of
clothing a type of medicine a weapon but
even looking at its shape how it
presents itself to us it is simply a
round band a layer added to a finger and
by this aspect it becomes a condensed
version of the periphery itself the
limit the wheel around an access the
wall around a city or the Magic Circle
of protection all these images relate to
the Ring of Power we're told in lore
that the Lord Sauron put his own power
into the ring making himself stronger by
binding his power into this forged
object but as I've explained like all
supplement like all tools this strategy
also made him weaker dependent on the
ring and so when the ring was lost his
power to affect the world was
drastically diminished we do not of
course have to understand this process
of supplement only in relation to magic
or to technology I've mentioned before
about that the supplement can be seen as
any thing which we add to our nature
anything which increases our capacity to
act in the world the ring could be an
army which a king adds to himself the
King binds his power into the army in
order to conquer and protect but if the
King loses his army then his power to
affect the world is also lost and he
actually becomes even more vulnerable
than he was before this is of course why
Sauron and the story loses his body
because he loses the ring for this
dependence on the outer world on
materiality for power is akin to
are depending on our own bodies for
affecting the world in physical terms
the supplement is ultimately an increase
of body in order to fully understand the
question of supplement it might be
useful to contrast this type of
influence by raw power to how someone
will pray worship or meditate in order
to increase one's inner strength or else
even in effecting the outer world
contrast the power of the Ring - how
teacher or a wise man affects the world
only by words and ideas even if that
wise person is killed his or her ideas
can continue to live and to be
transmitted they can continue to
transform the world for millennia after
the tyrants weapons and army are long
gone the Ring of Power is not only a
tool not only akin to a covering or to
clothing but ultimately the ring is an
ornament
now the symbolism of the ornament
participates in some of the most
difficult and the most mysterious
aspects of reality but if we do want to
understand why the ring makes one
invisible seems important to at least
touch a little bit on the strange
symbolism of ornamentation you see an
ornament is the ultimate supplement an
ornament is something which we add to a
person or to an object but plays no
practical purpose in what it ornaments
it is an alien form form foreign to the
nature of where it is surrounding myself
by a metal chariot like a car
supplements my capacity to travel
directly but putting a pattern of
flowers on a chair has nothing to do
with the act of City it is completely
alien to the chair nature of the chair
just like an order
on a sword would be alien to the sword
nature of the sword the ornament is only
added to make the chair stand out from
other chairs the sword stand out from
other swords how would I know which
chair is the king's throne and not just
any other chair
it is usually through a form of mark a
form of ornamentation so like technology
the ornament can be a way of increasing
one's influence increasing one's power
marking how special one is think for
example of a medal on a champion or a
war hero think of a badge on a military
uniform or on a police officer in Rome
wearing an ornamental purple band on
one's vestment was only permitted to
aristocracy and similar laws can be
found in other cultures as well of
course the ultimate example of the
ornament is the king's crown but we can
talk about that maybe in another video
the mystery in the ornament has to do
with the problem of showing and hiding
imagine you get a tattoo to attract
attention to differentiate yourself
Magda you put on makeup to enhance your
natural beauty it is there to increase
your glow let's call it to increase your
glory but this is artificial to an
extent yes we want to feature to attract
attention to something but like an
insecure man with a very expensive
sports car at some point the question
becomes whether you are overcompensating
for something that is lacking so the
situation is also a paradox it can in
fact make something special but if you
push the ornament too far well think for
example of how we carve vines into
ornamental patterns on architectural
tails a vine can be beautiful but a vine
is also a parasite and if it takes over
it begins to hide rather than show at
one point does one vanish behind one's
tattoos and one what point does makeup
cease to be an enhancement of beauty and
become a way to hide our own ugliness
when does ornament become a mask you see
this is the process I wish the ornament
pushed to its extreme can at some point
make one disappear the inverted
hierarchy in the Lord of the Rings just
like a aging woman can let herself
become a slave to her makeup the
dependence on the Rings forged by Sauron
becomes a kind of slavery for those who
are willing to take advantage of the
power they offer we see this most
wrongly of course in the ring raids and
in Gollum but for us today in the world
of smartphones this should not seem like
such a mystery by relying too much on
our capacity to increase our power buy
tools buy supplements technology weapons
we create that inverted hierarchy
because the tools we create always both
make us stronger and weaker at the same
time we are constantly in danger of
becoming dependent becoming the subjects
of that which is meant to serve us
whether it is the state money power
technology or whether it is more
immediately the gratifications of our
bodily desires like our desire for food
or for sex desires which are there to
keep us alive
that is the constant paradox of all
human endeavors and the lesson we learn
from stories about magic this paradox
shows itself even more clearly in the
modern age where you know many of us who
have often believed and advocated for
all the development of science and
technology thought that it would bring a
kind of moral perfect moral world of
moral hierarchy but as we see our very
tools slip from our grasps as we find
ourself more and more dependent on our
system our computers our gadgets we
discover ourselves to be on what seems
like an unstoppable binding of our power
in these tools that we have created and
as we stand on the verge of the
artificial intelligent intelligence
singularity we notice that we have most
probably already given our will and
power to this Dark Lord for having been
seduced by the power of the Ring it is
possible that many of us have already
become ring wraiths I hope you enjoyed
my interpretation of the ring in the
Lord of the Rings I will not be doing a
video only on the Lord of the Rings in
general but if there is something else
in the Lord of the Rings or in Tolkien's
work that you find might be of interest
to people please go ahead and put that
in the comments and if I have enough
comments I might just do that on some
other aspect of the of the epic I want
to tell everybody that finally there is
a way to support me on my website if you
go to the symbolic WorldCom the symbolic
world comm slash support you will find a
way to support me financially for those
who were leaving patreon who have
already left patreon you can go there
I've also learned that subscribe star
seems to be working again and so for
those who want us to support that
platform which has been an alternative a
free-speech alternative to patreon you
can also go there and find my
my page there Jonathan page Oh on
subscribe star I will be putting all
those links down below in the
description and so thank you everybody
once again for your support as usual
please share this video subscribe if you
haven't subscribed and I will see you
soon